mais je crois que la la conception de
Madame Popard est assez simpliste en
terme pour ses élections vous êtes déjà
d'accord on va écouter non non la
réalité c'est que aujourd'hui le Front
National a réussi un exploit c'est de
d'être présent dans tous les cantons de
de cô d'or et de France quasiment à
quelques exceptions près et le résultat
aujourd'hui est historique le Front
National a des résultats qui qui lui
permettent aujourd'hui un ancrage local
on va faire à peu près 7 ou 8 seconds
tours on attend les résultats définitifs
ce qui était du jamais vu évidemment la
question c'est combien d'élus parce que
des secondes cours ça donne pas des élus
et ça permet pas de peser je vais être
d'accord avec Madame Popard si ça lui
fait plaisir c'est que l'élection n'est
pas terminée pas du tout en vous fassiez
plaisir hein franchement l'élection
n'est pas terminé je peux pas vous dire
combien
d'élus en espéré combien voilà mais un
élu serait très bien on en a un seul en
France aujourd'hui pour toute la France
on a un seul conseiller général si on
pouvait avoir un un conseiller
départemental en cor ser moins de si
vous avez gagner un canton non je pense
qu'au niveau national il y en aura
peut-être de 300 vous gagnez pardon si
vous